do you think that we've gotten any
better I mean listen you go back into
the 50s in the 60s and that's not
necessarily something humanity wants to
be proud of and how people were treated
but do you think that we've gotten any
better in some ways yet in some places
and some in some places some societies
deal with it the thing that'll better I
think that Richards character does and
his and he says it in the film is he's a
skillful therapist he's a skillful
listener and that's not enough to feel
it's not enough to be empathetic it's
it's not enough you there's an element
of skill that has to be there as well
and part of skill is patience mm-hmm and
the willingness to just be there and
also to take the risk I mean there was
one thing you responded to about the
fear that a therapist has we were
rehearsing and you know Waltons playing
a very his mask is a very aggressive
personality and I I was having trouble
dealing with us and my own instinct as
an alpha man is to fight back and I know
this is wrong that impulse is not going
to work here so I was actually talking
to Aaron Stern about this who the the
shrink that John worked with and we
worked with and he said look you just
have to acknowledge it you have to say
to him I said look he you're scaring
everyone right now we get it it's okay
go back and sit down because we have
work to do just acknowledge it yeah and
it was it allowed me to deal with those
situations also how it allowed him to
deal with those actions and be able to
back off yeah to back off yeah because I
was because I was heard yeah but that
was the dance with Walton Peter and
Bradley and Richard and it was a dance
the moments were so unpredictable
yeah they yeah one thing that helps in
actors to not know the result yeah yeah
and I'm trying to follow was they're not
ad-lib that's not the right way but a
little bit of room for them to it was a
tremendous amount of room for them to
its behave and then react um you know my
my character they
the only way I could function in this
was to set up situations in which which
is quite the prefrontal lobe situations
I work it out I think about it I'm
rational and I setup something I think
will work mm-hmm will create a positive
dynamic but then I have to just watch I
have to be reactive in the situation as
it evolves because I can't know that's
going to happen with these guys so we we
did improvise through a lot of these
plays some of them felt they felt like
just beyond real well that's their skill
yeah I mean it it is it is also
observing because we you know with the
Christ
since I'm the only Christ here you know
I mean you have to like you have to kind
of really enjoying the oh right now but
we you know we had to make each other
laugh a little bit because it got so
heavy and question really like this is
heavy subject matter and that's some of
the scenes were pretty tense but you're
all pretty funny people well set like
off to the side we came up with this
whole thing that were the three Christ's
detective agency and then we will solve
your crime solvers probably save your
soul and why did you fish keep looking
at me and it was just kind of going off
there I mean they're there they are
there they're amazing people I want to
go back to something you said earlier
about are we getting better or are we
getting worse and I think Richards right
some societies are better at dealing
with this than other but others but what
I think what what I think we have gotten
worse about is our capacity to listen
and I'm not talking about politics right
now I'm talking about sure you are just
well it's out of course that's a part of
the root of it absolutely but I'm
talking about just just in an elevator
with somebody I mean because of the
phone you know they're there we don't
have the capacity to just sit and look
in someone's face even at dinner for 30
minutes uninterrupted and and that's you
know and for what dr. stone does in this
and what is required of someone to truly
have the desire not just the empathy but
the desire
to understand someone requires that kind
of focus and attention and I don't know
that we have that something happens in
society yeah and I hope we get it